160 votants 156 exprimé majorité sont
19% 13 contre 43 le projet de loi
prorogeant l'état d'urgence sanitaire
est donc adopté
[Musique]
au nom de cette urgence sanitaire le
parlement l'assemblée nationale du moins
va s'asseoir sur la séparation des
pouvoirs
ce chantage à la responsabilité vous
nous dites à chaque fois que si nous
sommes contre nous sommes irresponsable
ce chantage à la responsabilité
il est indigne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous ne pouvons pas je suis ministre
donnait tous les trois ou quatre mois de
chèque en blanc au gouvernement sans
débattre du fond de cette stratégie
sanitaire
il paraît évident que nous n'allons pas
pouvoir traverser toute l'année de
livres 21 uniquement avec des mesures de
confinement de déconfinement dirt
continent ou de couvre-feu
[Musique]